bitte sehr sabrina der buchweizen kuchen
mit kokosnuss butter mandeln und nüssen
erdbeeren und rhabarber
zuckerfrei mit pistazien
danke glutenfrei ohne milchprodukte
danke sehr nett geschenkt guten appetit
heutzutage ist essen nicht mehr so
einfach wo immer wir hingehen wird uns
gesagt dass wir bestimmte lebensmittel
essen sollten und andere nicht man sagt
uns wir würden zu viel essen einige
lebensmittel seien schlecht für uns
andere nicht ethnisch vertretbar und
ihre produktion und ihr konsum seien
schlecht für die umwelt wir müssen
darauf achten was wir essen denn es sei
voller konservierungsstoffe und
pestizide und wir sollten vegan werden
dass es besser wäre wenn wir auf gluten
fleisch fisch eier zucker milch und alle
verarbeiteten lebensmittel verzichten
würden all dies schafft eine weit
verbreitete angst und verwirrung auf
unseren tischen zwischen wahrheit
pseudowissenschaft wunder diäten und
neuen dogmen die die traditionelle art
wie wir uns ernähren infrage stellen
suchen viele besorgte menschen nach
lösungen durch alternative und kuriose
ernährungsweisen
ich esse
also bin ich
[Musik]
guten morgen guten morgen so eine schöne
überraschung megane vegetarische und
glutenfreie gerichtet zu finden sehr
interessant ich habe okay sagen wir mal
wir sind sehr vorsichtig was
unverträglichkeiten und allergien
betrifft es gibt verschiedene arten der
ernährung wir müssen also über alles auf
dem laufenden sein
allergene auch hast du das gesehen ja
auch allergene stimmt
sie finden die 14 haupt allergene in der
speisekarte
da können sie schon sehen was sie wählen
dürfen und was nicht
das brot ist natürlich glutenfrei
buchweizen brot und zwei schwarze reis
cracker es ist heutzutage nicht einfach
ein restaurant zu führen es gibt viele
menschen die sabrina die die speisekarte
durchgehen und nach zutaten suchen die
sie unbedingt vermeiden wollen die
gluten und laktose aber nicht nur
als hauptgang haben wir auberginen und
spinat mit petersilie angebraten und
dann
ich bin jetzt viel glücklicher und fühle
mich sogar frei essen zu gehen denn
endlich gibt es mehr bewusstsein für
menschen mit
lebensmittelunverträglichkeiten aber
auch für die qualität der lebensmittel
im allgemeinen und im vergleich zu
früher ist es jetzt ein vergnügen
auswärts zu essen
sabrina ist 54 jahre alt und testet seit
geraumer zeit die reaktionen ihres
körpers auf bestimmte lebensmittel
seit meiner kindheit hat mich der
geschmack von fleisch immer sehr gestört
aber auch der geruch seit ich klein bin
ich muss sagen dass meine mutter als
gute lombarden mich alle arten von
fleisch probieren ließ so dass ich genau
weiß was mir fehlt und was ich nicht mag
als ich aufwuchs war die grausamkeit
gegenüber tieren der auslöser für meine
entscheidung vegetarierin zu werden
meine entscheidung nicht völlig auf
gluten zu verzichten sondern sagen wir
sehr vorsichtig damit umzugehen beruht
auf meinem körperlichen wohlbefinden
problem als das problem begann als ich
feststellte dass mein bauch
angeschwollen war was nicht heißt dass
ich zur jacke hatte oder an
unverträglichkeiten litt darauf hatte
ich mich untersuchen lassen aber es war
vor allem eine reaktion auf einige
getreidesorten die nicht mehr so gesund
sind wie früher
und deshalb hatte ich diese reaktion ich
fühle mich stoffwechsel mäßig viel
besser weniger beschwert weniger müde
und erschöpft
ein arzt kennt meine
ernährungsgewohnheiten und meine
blutuntersuchung sind gut
es gibt keine besondere
mangelerscheinungen
[Musik]
ich meide auch mais und weizen ich esse
viel roggen und gerste
denn selbst wenn sie gluten enthalten
sind sie viel besser verdaulich
das esse habe ich keine stoffwechsel
probleme mehr und mein magen spielt
nicht mehr an
und auch all die anderen die überhaupt
kein gluten enthalten wie hafer amaranth
buch weizen und reis die esse ich
regelmäßig
ich esse lieber keine verarbeiteten
lebensmittel wo sie glutenfreie
teigtaschen verkaufen mache ich sie
lieber selbst
ich lasse mir ein wenig zeit es ist
nicht so zeitaufwendig und kompliziert
unser leben ist zu hektisch es gibt die
zeit dinge zu tun es braucht nur 15 bis
20 minuten um gute nudeln zu machen
an athen frei geht also
nur zehn frei für immer
[Musik]
zum frühstück proteine haferflocken und
erdnussbutter zimmer
[Musik]
proteine kohlenhydrate und fette es ist
eine vollwertige mahlzeit ich verdauen
ist schnell
ich filtere haferflocken wenn ich den
teil wegnehme der fester ist weniger auf
das frühstück der champions
manche menschen haben beschlossen einige
lebensmittel aus ihrer ernährung zu
streichen andere haben eine individuelle
diät entwickelt michael ist 24 jahre alt
und sportler die mahlzeiten die er
zubereitet bestimmen seinen tagesablauf
von morgens bis spät abends
der reis ist von letzter nacht um 2 uhr
morgens ich konnte ihn nicht ganz auf
essen das wird heute die vorspann zu
sein
jetzt bereite ich das hähnchen zu ich
werde es würzen den reis holy später
heraus
karotten und fenchel denn gemüse ist
wichtig
normalerweise beginne ich um 9 mit der
zubereitung des frühstücks gleich nach
dem aufstehen
ich esse um halb zehn und dann wieder um
halb zwei zwei je nachdem wie viele
kohlenhydrate ich esse denn wenn ich das
tue wenn ich sicher dass ich schon viel
früher hungrig bin
aber wenn ich eine normale mahlzeit zu
mir nehme kann ich etwa drei stunden
wieder stehen und so weiter bis zu acht
bis zehn mahlzeiten pro tag eigentlich
sind es vier mahlzeiten mit mindestens
vier weiteren zwischenmahlzeiten
ich ziehe es vor jeden tag einmal zu
kochen anstatt ständig zu kochen und
mich dabei zu stressen
ersten sollte kein stress sein
vielleicht erste ich jetzt drei scheiben
und später noch mal drei scheiben damit
es nicht langweilig wird und ich
verschiedene geschmacksrichtungen habe
da ich nur reis hühnchen eier karotten
und andere wenige dinge essen muss sich
die geschmäcker variieren um meinen
appetit anzuregen
meine freunde sagen dass ich besessen
bin dass ich verrückt bin
das ist das häufig der adjektiv das ich
höre aber am ende kommen sie alle zu mir
und bittet mich um rat also bin ich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so verrückt
[Musik]
wenn ich etwas esse das von meiner
üblichen ernährung abweicht spüre ich
sofort einen unterschied in meinem
marken den ich nicht ganz erklären kann
ja es ist wie ein gewicht ein sofortiges
aufblähen
deshalb beschränke ich mich
normalerweise auf diese wenigen dinge
ok genau ein kilo jetzt teile ich es auf
so weiß ich wie viel mehr oder weniger
ich jeweils es
um 100 gramm ziehe ich linien
nur um keine waage zu benutzen damit ich
mir keinen stress machen
am liebsten schneide ich das hähnchen in
stücke und mische es unter den rest so
dass es ein einziger gang wird
das ist zwar nicht schön anzusehen aber
es ist praktisch
[Musik]
ich esse nie etwas rohes ich koche
lieber alles ich könnte zum beispiel
karotten in meinem salat essen oder
fenchel aber ich mag kein rohes gemüse
und schon gar kein fleisch
ich könnte nie wieder zurückkehren
selbst wenn ich wollte es wäre ein
problem wieder bei jemandem zu hause zu
essen wenn ich zum essen eingeladen bin
esse ich immer alles ich mag alles aber
wenn das essen zu stark gewürzt ist zu
viel oder etwas ungekochte butter dabei
ist stört mich das und ich fühle mich
schwer
[Musik]
eine sich wiederholende diät viele
andere stören würde aber für mich ist es
die einzig mögliche
[Musik]
ich glaube ich werde weiter zu essen ich
würde sagen dass ich mich für immer so
ernähren würde weil ich mich damit gut
fühle eigentlich fühle ich mich
großartig seit ich angefangen habe so zu
essen ich habe mich auch vorher gut
gefühlt aber auf eine andere art und
weise ich war mir nicht so bewusst wie
ich es jetzt bin auch wenn ich mich
immer gesund ernährt habe meine mutter
und mein vater haben immer gute sachen
gekocht früher war es ein vorgetäuschtes
wohlbefinden weil ich an dieser umstände
gewöhnt war so dass man nicht wirklich
weiß wie man sich fühlen konnte wenn man
das richtige essen ist die
energiegeladen man ist sich voller leben
fühlt im grunde genommen wenn man gut
ist ist man voller energie
es war das mit dem halben kilo reis
nicht ein halbes kilo es waren etwa 100
gramm pro 100 gramm das ist das was
marty direkt und wächst genau zerkocht
vielleicht mit ein bisschen mehr wasser
als sonst ich lege wert darauf nur
schweine pferde
presse nur tiere die mehr wiegen als ich
aber ich sehe du ist veganer
war einmal die woche könnte es ja mal
versuchen
[Musik]
so sei der vor 44 jahren in turin
geboren wurde beschloss nach einer zeit
zwischen lissabon und london mit seiner
familie ins tessin zu ziehen für eine
bessere lebensqualität
ich bin mit einer mediterranen ernährung
aufgewachsen die wir vor 40 jahren
mediterrane nannten das heißt dass wir
vor 40 jahren dachten margarine sei
gesund dann fanden wir heraus dass sie
im vergleich zur butter schlechter ist
auf jeden fall war es eine strikte
niveau ernährung und im extremen
gegensatz dazu haben wir als wir in
london ankamen und jeden tag
tiefkühlpizza und tragen das heißt
dann begannen wir zu recherchieren und
fragten uns wie wir länger und gesünder
leben könnten und
welche art von ernährung wer in diesem
fall für unser kind wählen würden so
kamen wir auf den veganismus
nicht nur veganer sondern auch roh
veganer die nichts von dem kochen was
sie essen
rohkost ist lebendige nahrung denn wenn
man lebensmittel frisch lässt also nicht
kocht bleiben alle nährwerte erhalten
sie werden nicht raus gekocht
ich habe darüber nachgedacht die
getrockneten kohlblätter zu machen wie
du gesagt hast
[Musik]
und mit der zubereitung des bürgers
anzufangen du solltest die sonnenblumen
wasser einlegen
wir verwenden ausgewählte arten des
kochens die im allgemeinen nicht als
kochen gelten wer trockenen lebensmittel
die temperatur geht nie über 42 grad in
einem belüfteten raum so als ob sie in
der sonne trocknen würden oder wir
fermentieren durch einlegen und andere
lebensmittel veränderungen aber nicht
durch kochen
vor allem für ihren sohn leonardo haben
sie sich für den roh veganismus
entschieden
[Musik]
wir dachten es wäre besser für unseren
sohn sich gesund zu ernähren auch weil
wir uns sorgen machten überall die
zusatzstoffe mit denen tiere gefüttert
werden damit sie schnell wachsen um auf
unserem tisch voller ungesunder produkte
zu landen
hormone pestizide
also haben wir beschlossen dass es
besser wäre alles zu essen was näher an
der natur ist
leonardo ernährt sich überwiegend vegan
nicht roh wie kann es macht uns nicht
viel aus ob er robben wird oder nicht
uns geht es darum ihm die gesündesten
lebensmittel zu geben
[Musik]
das ist ein mandl kokos kuchen und wir
haben hier schokolade erdbeere und
orange die creme ist aus cashew nüssen
und früchten gemacht
konnte man früher nur fleisch käse und
traditionelle produkte finden so findet
man heute auf den märkten von lugano und
bellinzona auf vegane und roh vegane
spezialitäten was zeigt dass die
neugierde auf diese ernährungsweise groß
ist mandl käse mit sonnen getrockneten
tomaten
bei einer rohen ernährung spürt man die
auswirkungen sofort das kann
leichtigkeit sein und gleichzeitig
sättigung
man fühlt sich nicht müde und schläfrig
direkt nach dem essen man hat mir
energie
eine schokolade zum mitnehmen oder zum
essen für unterwegs jetzt okay
weil wir auf vegane ernährung umgestellt
haben sind wir fast nie krank
auch leonardo wird nur sehr selten krank
das ist sehr interessant denn viele
mütter sagen normalerweise wenn ein kind
im kindergarten krank ist sind auch alle
anderen kinder zu hause kann
leonardo ist immer in der schule weil er
selten krank ist
wir essen nur biologische lebensmittel
und wenn wir sie roh essen müssen wir
sehr vorsichtig sein um unnatürliche
pestizide und verunreinigungen so weit
wie möglich zu vermeiden
ich nehme ein retter
das ist köstlich haben sie schon
gegessen
nein ist es das erste mal
im moment ist der rap sehr beliebt es
ist eine art brotlaib aus karotten und
leinsamen getrocknet bei 42 grad sie
trocknen fünf bis sechs stunden lang
dann füllen wir sie mit karotten
apfelessig rüben und kesha käse also
rohen käse und salatblättern
je nach saison machen wir noch ein
bisschen fenchel dazu oder oliven kommt
darauf an das ist im moment sehr beliebt
[Musik]
die gerichte der raw veganen ernährung
können sehr einfach sein aber wenn sie
etwas aufwendiger sind kann die
vorbereitung einige stunden dauern und
josi und tatjana verbringen ganze tage
mit dieser tätigkeit die für sie fast
eine mission ist
ich freue mich wenn die leute bei uns
essen
auch wenn es nur ein oder zweimal die
woche ist zweimal im monat ist um unser
essen zu probieren ich freue mich dass
sie sich gesund ernähren zur abwechslung
mal vegan essen und die rohkost
kennenlernen können
ich glaube dass sich die mentalität der
menschen ändert in dreißig bis fünfzig
jahren wird es viele menschen geben die
sich vegan ernähren
[Musik]
ich habe immer viel sport getrieben vor
allem radfahren selbst in meiner jugend
habe ich viel sport gemacht hat mir
wurde immer gesagt dass kohlenhydrate
für die ausübung von sport für ausdauer
und widerstandskraft unerlässlich sind
im grunde sind kohlenhydrate der
treibstoff und ich habe sie immer
gegessen zb obst brot müsli zum
frühstück mittags ein teller nudeln
immer vollkornnudeln aber trotzdem
nudeln beim ein stück kuchen als
nachtisch
eiweiß fleisch oder fisch oder
pflanzliches eiweiß linsen oder
kichererbsen
antonio ferretti seit seiner jugend
spitzensportler und journalist für
verlobt hat vor kurzem festgestellt dass
einige seiner ernährungsregeln nach
denen er jahrelang gelebt hatte nicht
mehr für seinen lebensstil geeignet
waren und so war es erforderlich einige
gewohnheiten zu ändern
ich bin fast 62 und habe vor allem in
den letzten drei bis vier jahren bemerkt
dass sich an muskulatur verliere so
genannter fettfreie körpermasse
ich war schon immer ziemlich dünn aber
ich habe wirklich muskeln verloren
auch wenn ich jeden tag radfahren sogar
auf langstrecken außerdem fahre ich
gerne ski langlauf trotzdem bemerkte ich
immer wieder dass die muskeln sogar die
an meinen beinen an definition verloren
dann lernte ich verschiedene
ernährungsberater kennen
und alle betonten dass es vor allem in
einem gewissen alter richtiges proteine
zu essen zwar so gut wie jeder mahlzeit
angefangen beim frühstück mittagessen es
sollte immer eiweiß enthalten seien vor
allem tierisches eiweiß
ein frühstück
sind die proteine normalerweise wachte
ich esse 5
und ein stück grün
und ein verwandeln dann esse ich ein
bisschen obst und manchmal ein oder zwei
scheiben brot wachteleier schmecken am
besten sie haben ein leichtes aroma ein
bisschen würze
es ist ein genuss sie zu essen dann habe
ich von einem ernährungswissenschaftler
gehört dass wachteleier seiner meinung
nach einen geringen einfluss auf den
cholesterinspiegel haben vor allem wenn
sie morgens gegessen werden
ich habe das nicht wirklich überprüft
aber sie sind teil dieser diät und ich
esse sie gern
dieser ernährungsumstellung ging es mir
nach ein paar monaten wieder viel wasser
konnte meine muskeln wieder spüren sogar
in den beinen sie schulten meine hosen
besser aus meine ich esse viel fleisch
aber auch für gemüse
rohes gemüse am abend gekocht ich würde
sagen dass der größte teil aus gemüse
besteht
auf räume mir erklärt hat wie man das
gleichgewicht in dieser ernährung
aufrecht erhält die sauren und die
basischen bestandteile der ernährung in
den letzten zwei jahren habe ich mich
also ist jünger gefühlt
[Musik]
schade
der verzicht auf tierische proteine kann
im laufe der zeit folgen haben vor allem
mangel erscheinen
ich muss sagen dass ich während meiner
radsport karriere als ich profi war von
dieser art makrobiotische ernährung
angezogen fangen wir mal gefangen war
sehr vollwertig mit wenig fleisch eine
zeitlang als ich rennen vor trainierte
ich vier fünf stunden am tag
ich habe versucht nur vollwertkost zu
essen ganz ohne fleisch
und ich wurde fast pluta
tatsächlich habe ich auch jetzt noch
einige folgen davon reisen und führt ihn
wird ist immerhin der grenze
auch das bessert sich jetzt aber der
verzicht auf tierische proteine kann
wirklich folgen haben
besonders in meinem alter immer noch
aktiv und in guter form sein will
in mailand treffen wir uns mit lorenz
die eine sehr extreme ernährungsweise
gewählt hat die in einem buch des
deutschen schriftstellers arno ehret
beschrieben wird der anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts in ascona auf
dem monteverdi tarr lebte
ja ich bin vor 67 jahren aus reinem
zufall zum foto ria geworden beim lesen
einiger seiten im internet sah ich immer
wieder vorschläge über fleisch denn also
fragte ich mich eigentlich esse ich sehr
wenig fleisch und auch nicht viel fisch
aber ich war neugierig ob das gesund ist
oder nicht
dann beschloss sich herauszufinden wer
er etwa ein arzt aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert anfang 1900 der hatte damit
begonnen menschen mit einer frischen
ernährung zu heilen
zu diesem zeitpunkt versuchte ich
erstmal zu verstehen was denn da
passiert ich sagte mir wenn es heilt
wird es wohl heißen dass es keinen
schaden anrichtet es entgiftet also
hilft ein längeres und gesünderes leben
zu führen glücklicher zu sein ich
erinnerte mich schon vegan ich hatte
auch getreide und eier weggelassen aber
ich es immer noch grünzeug
also begann ich die reifen nicht als
plötzliche kehrtwende sondern ich ließ
langsam nudeln brot und alle
getreidesorten weg
und es war die größte entdeckung meines
lebens ich habe wirklich eine große
menge zu mir genommen ich habe eine
leichtigkeit und vitalität gewonnen die
ich vorher nicht hatte nach einer
gewissen zeit ohne hat man kein
bedürfnis mehr danach
[Musik]
am anfang waren alle etwas beunruhigt
weil ich eine ganze menge gewicht
verloren habe aber wie gesagt erst löst
man seinen körper auf dann nimmt man ihn
wieder an sogar meine muskeln haben sich
aufgelöst denn auch sie waren
verunreinigt so dass sie neu aufgebaut
werden mussten genau das was er sagt ist
auch bei mir passiert ich habe eine
ganze menge gewicht verloren dann habe
ich alles wieder zurückgewonnen genau
wie vorher
[Musik]
pflanzen beschenken uns mit ihren
früchten der es halb essen wir frutarier
auch gemüse früchte die gemüse früchte
die wir verzehren sind alle früchte die
samen enthalten
auberginen tomaten paprika zucchini
gurken
auch oliven und avocados die fetthaltig
sind und fett ist sehr wichtig das
brauchen wir zum leben
[Musik]
essen keine gemüsesorten die nur blätter
enthalten wie spinat kohl blumenkohl
oder artischocken brokkoli spargel
fenchel
das sind alles pflanzen die die leben
wollen und
dann knollen wie kartoffeln die sind
voller stärke die essen wie nicht
mein frühstück beginnt mit einem apfel
es gibt auch apfel frutarier die essen
nur äpfel aber
das kann dann zwischen menschlich
schwierig werden ich lebe von den
kontakten zu anderen menschen und es ist
schon so schwer auswärts zu essen
wenn ich anfange nur noch äpfel zu essen
dann werden mich alle meiden und mit
äpfeln bewerfen
die wahren gründe für die frucht
revolution sind hauptsächlich ethischer
natur
die menschen entwickeln sich weiter und
verstehen was besser für sie selbst ist
und auch für die umwelt in der sie leben
man muss respekt vor allem haben es geht
nicht nur um gesundheit sondern auch um
respekt für sich selbst und alle
lebewesen also auch für tiere und
pflanzen das ist das wichtigste
[Musik]
lorenzer ist mit dieser entscheidung
nicht allein und um das zu zeigen bringt
sie uns zum ersten veganen fruit
arischen restaurant in italien
[Musik]
bitte sehr pizza eine frische pizza
mit kochbananen als grüne bananen die im
ofen gekocht und dann verarbeitet werden
oben drauf haben wir groß gemüse
das ist das einzige afrikanische
restaurant in italien es ist wichtig den
menschen alternative ernährungsweisen
anzubieten und sie zu ermutigen über
eine ernährung nachzudenken die nicht
spezifisch ist also nicht natürlich für
die menschliche rasse die erfahrung die
er im laufe der jahre bei der
zubereitung traditioneller gerichte
gesammelt hat hat den chefkoch fernando
bruno dazu gebracht eine küche
vorzuschlagen der er sich selbst näher
fühlt
da ich zuerst veganer also obst esser
war beschloss ich in meinem restaurant
eine alternative küche zu den
klassischen standards der küche
anzubieten die tiere oder tierische
produkte verwendet
denn die italiener haben eine große
tradition der rotarischen küche in jeder
region
das ist ein frisches tatar das nur aus
früchten besteht
es wird mit jack frucht gemacht einer
exotischen frucht die mit getrockneten
tomaten zubereitet wird und
[Musik]
manche früchte sind außergewöhnlich
nehmen sie einfach einen klassischen
kürbis legen sie ihn für etwa 20 minuten
in den ofen bei einer nicht so hohen
temperatur sagen wir etwa 150 grad dann
ist der kürbis gar und wir können das
fruchtfleisch zu einer creme verarbeiten
die man für verschiedene menüs verwenden
kann
[Musik]
zum beispiel ein schmackhaftes gericht
aus bio china mit kürbisfleisch und
sonnen getrockneten biotomaten
das ist bei adrian sehr beliebt
obst und gemüse der saison aber auch
zutaten die von weither kommen
[Musik]
ich habe die kochbanane entdeckt mit der
ich auch erst die gänge machen kann oder
sogar eine pizza die steht der
klassischen mail pizza in nichts nach
ist aber auf jeden fall gesünder denn es
ist eine frucht pizza
die kochbanane wird im ofen gegart wenn
sie schwarz ist man schält sie dann
püriert man sie mit hoher
geschwindigkeit
dann wird man sie mit nativem olivenöl
also der sorte ohne steine einer prise
rosa himalaya salz und verarbeitet sie
wie einen pizzateig
das gleiche gilt für brot man kann damit
zum beispiel canapés oder gebäck zu
bereiten
ich mache sogar platini und niki
unter den kunden sind manche die einfach
neugierig sind und viele bekehrte
[Musik]
die qualität der lebensmittel wie
fleisch oder thunfisch ist schlecht sie
sind günstiger geworden fisch ist voll
von schwermetallen und so weiter
abgesehen von der ganzen veganer debatte
müssen wir also die qualität der
lebensmittel berücksichtigen die nicht
mehr dieselbe ist wie früher
motorisches essen ist hoch energetischen
nahrhaft sie ledig auf da sie sehr hohe
schwingungen hat
es wurde gerade erst gepflückt und nicht
behandelt und es ist so herrlich so
bunte teller zu sehen voller leben und
echt
rotarische ernährung ist für jeden
geeignet natürlich braucht man etwas
geduld geduld beim kochen wir sollten in
der vergangenheit zurückblicken und
wieder entdecken was unsere mütter
früher gekocht haben all die zeit die
sie damit verbracht haben diese
wunderbaren gerichte zu kochen
[Musik]
mein frühstück beginnt um 5.30 es dauert
etwa eine halbe stunde wie schwieger
alles weil es für mich wichtig ist meine
kalorien zuvor während des ganzen tages
zu kennen denn mein ziel ist es in
perfekter form zu sein
mein körper mein aussehen ist meine
visitenkarte
[Musik]
simon ist personaltrainer 44 jahre alt
und essen ist für ihn viel mehr als sich
nur zu ernähren er verzichtet immer
wieder auf die freuden des guten essens
um fit zu bleiben und um eine
persönliche studie über die bestmögliche
ernährung durchzuführen
[Musik]
ich ernähre mich überwiegend natürlich
mit viel grün zeigt ich halte mich an
die fünf portionen mindestens fünf
mahlzeiten am tag
meine zwischenmahlzeiten bestehen meist
aus obst je nachdem welches obst gerade
sie so hat
mein mittagessen besteht hauptsächlich
aus eiweiß also gemüse hat einigen
proteine
während ich kohlenhydrate lieber auf das
abendessen verschieben um den schlaf
auszugleichen
kulturelle elemente ich habe die
ernährungserziehung zu meinem lebensstil
gemacht denn wir sind was wir essen und
wenn wir junk food essen wir gerne sage
sie haben gleich unser körper einem
müller
für menschen wie simone deren
bodybuilding wettbewerben teilnimmt ist
eine bewusste ernährung unerlässlich
private in der welt an ich habe viele
diäten ausprobiert vor allem weil ich
für meine arbeit gerne experimentieren
um andere beraten zu können welche diät
am besten zum lebensstil der person
passt aber auch aus neugierde um zu
sehen wie wirksam sie tatsächlich ist
ich habe auch eine zeitlang die paläo
diät verfolgt hier an meinem umfeld sehr
bekannt also viele proteine und sehr
wenige kohlenhydrate natürlich begleitet
von obst und gemüse
ich habe auch die pick up probiert die
diät der fußballer über den man sehr
viel ist
die frage wie mit der qualität der
nahrung zusammenhängt
auch nur für kurze zeit sie war zu
komplex um sie zu befolgen
ich habe die blutgruppen diät und die
varia diät ausprobiert
heute erinnere ich mich
kohlenhydratreichen bis zu 60 65 prozent
bei 3000 kalorien also eine sehr große
menge an kohlenhydraten
gerade weil er so viele alternativen an
sich selbst ausprobiert hat kennt er
ihre stärken und schwächen
regula die schöne in der regel tun
diejenigen die sich eine vegane
ernährung entscheiden dies vor allem aus
bewusstseins gründen wenn sich eine
person einer meiner schüler dafür
entscheidet rate ich ihm sich von einem
ernährungsberater begleiten zu lassen
[Musik]
vor allem bei menschen die auf
kohlenhydrate verzichten gibt es
probleme ihre muskelmasse wird
weggefressen
das erschwert den wiederaufbau des
muskeltonus denn sobald man ihn etwas
mehr kalorien gibt neigen sie dazu zu
nehmen und das wollen sie nicht
[Musik]
jeder muss sein eigenes maß an
ausgewogenheit in der ernährung finden
denn wir alle haben unsere eigene
persönliche beziehung zum essen
mit meiner arbeit versuche ich den
menschen zu helfen ihr eigenes
gleichgewicht zu finden das nicht
unbedingt mein eigenes sein muss
meines strikt an meinen job und die
wettbewerber gebunden andere haben
andere notwendigkeiten
[Musik]
heutzutage gibt es viele ernährungs
moden mal werden die leute veganer mal
veganer dann essen sie kein gluten mehr
obwohl sie nicht wirklich zöliakie haben
es gibt von allem ein bisschen auch ich
habe als junges mädchen viele
verschiedene diäten ausprobiert weil ich
sehen wollte was für mich funktioniert
und ich glaube die beste erfahrung ist
die die man an sich selbst ausprobiert
es stimmt es gab eine zeit in der ich
zielstrebig war vor etwa 20 bis 30
jahren da es sich hauptsächlich ruhe und
glaubte an die wissenschaft hinter der
rohen ernährung und ich hatte
tatsächlich einen nutzen davon
als ich dann im ehrungs beraterin wurde
verstand ich natürlich wie gut man sich
fühlen kann wie viel besser wenn man
sich frei fühlt und sehr
abwechslungsreiches essen zu sich nimmt
und all die einzigartigen vorteile die
das für die gesundheit bringen kann
es ist wichtig dass ernährungsexperten
wie barbara naldi die öffentlichkeit auf
die vorteile und auch die gefahren einer
jeden diät hinweisen
es gibt ein paar berühmte amerikanische
stars die sich zum beispiel vegan
ernähren im moment gibt es einen boom
dieser diät aber wenn ich daran denke
als ich 20 30 jahre alt war gab es schon
den boom der veganen und makrobiotisch
diäten das sind wählen wie bei trends
die meist nichts mit dem wirklichen
instinkt eines menschen zu tun haben
natürlich gibt es auch neue arten von
obsession zum beispiel die orthodoxie
die ein amerikanischer arzt vor einigen
jahren benannt hat es ist ein begriff
der von der allgemeinmedizin noch nicht
akzeptiert wird
aber er wird verwendet um menschen zu
beschreiben die völlig besessen von
gesunder ernährung sind
alles muss biologisch seien gesund die
luft muss rein sein das wasser muss rein
und destilliert seien kein café früh
schlafen nicht rauchen kein alkohol
keine aufregung
ich habe solche menschen erlebt ich habe
patienten die ohne meine zustimmung
niemals ein stück schokolade naschen
würden sie haben solche angst dass ein
stückchen schokolade schädlich sein
könnte
ich tue mein bestes und ihnen die angst
vor dem essen zu nehmen bei meinen
patienten mache ich das gegenteil indem
ich ihnen erkläre dass wir auch ein
instinkt für dinge haben die in der
natur nicht wachsen das wie sie aber
genießen weil wir mit diesen
geschmäckern aufgewachsen sind wenn wir
also kleine mengen dieser dinge zu uns
nehmen ohne angst zu haben können wir
davon profitieren indem wir uns das
innere verlangen nach einem stück kuchen
einem kleinen stück käse erfüllen ohne
zu übertreiben sich aber von dieser
besessenheit zu befreien
[Musik]